recently ubisoft announced their latest
addition to the tom clancy world
x defiant or laughing face emoji
effient or e fiant bloody hell who comes
up with these names
being that it bears the tom clancy name
there must be a huge amount of story
backing up this game
so in this video i'm going to piece
together everything we know so far and
give some background as to why these
groups are fighting over these small
arenas
you know before some of the official
full-scale in-depth law is released
let's start with the most obvious and
familiar part the factions
now they've stated that more will be
added after release but we'll tackle
these as they come
for now we have the wolves echelon
cleaners and outcasts
the wolves were featured in tom clancy's
ghost recon break point
lieutenant cole d walker was a ghost
team leader
the ghosts formerly known as delta
company first battalion fifth special
forces group
is a tier one special missions unit of
the us army
walker was growing more and more
frustrated with the increased
politicization of the military
after an incident in afghanistan and
then the following court-martial
he was medically discharged from the
armed forces
in response walker returned to his base
and executed his commanding officer
in the year 2023 walker rallied several
ghosts both former
and current and went rogue calling
themselves
the wolves
[Music]
echelon was featured in tom clancy's
splinter cell franchise
which had a number of games released
between 2002 and 2013.
echelon is essentially a worldwide
network of international intelligence
agencies
and interceptors that seizes
communication signals and routes them
back to the national security agency for
analysis
beginning around the cold war the agency
has since grown into the second
third and fourth echelon as a top-secret
initiative within the various
intelligence branches of the national
security agency
they are the equivalent of the special
forces in the modern age of information
warfare
when intelligence deemed critical to
national security could not be obtained
by traditional means
echelon was granted clearance to conduct
physical operations
its existence denied by the us
government echelon deployed units of
splinter cells
like a slither of glass a splinter cell
is small sharp
and nearly invisible while the story of
these games ended following the
blacklist attacks in 2012
due to a lack of interest the splinter
cell franchise seems to have been
abandoned
however they have appeared in a number
of other tom clancy titles such as ghost
recon wildlands and bolivia 2019
rave of six siege in 2020 and ghost
recon break point
in 2025
the clean is first featured in tom
clancy's the division
after a biological attack crippled new
york city following black friday in 2015
government forces constructed a
quarantine zone in the middle of
manhattan
while these government forces abandoned
the area due to the growing hostile
presence
the people who were involved in helping
during this time construction workers
sanitation truck drivers etc were left
behind
unwilling to give up and see this city
burned to the ground they decided it was
up to them to do what no one else had
the guts to do
and to burn this virus and the city to
the ground no no wait just the virus
they want the city
the outcasts are also from the division
franchise they first feature in the
division two
seven months after the initial outbreak
in 2016.
government forces in washington dc have
created a quarantine zone on roosevelt
island
infected civilians from hospitals and
refugee camps were rounded up
and shipped to the island the zone's
hastily erected facilities quickly
turned into a living nightmare for both
the patients and medical staff
roosevelt island survivors were severely
traumatized by the horrors they were
forced to endure
the outcasts are these bitter survivors
they are hell-bent on revenge against
society that allowed this forced
quarantine to happen
with horrific conditions that led to a
number of unnecessary deaths
their focus is to punish the guilty by
spreading sickness
and murdering indiscriminately
so how do all of these groups come
together the wolves in echelon are
already in the same universe as we've
seen with a number of crossovers
especially with the most recent one in
breakpoint where they landed on aurora
to help the ghosts
but as we all know the division
franchise is its own standalone tom
clancy universe
so how on earth have they been able to
cross over
after a bit of research the answer is so
obvious it's been in front of us the
whole time
the developers were actually pretty
smart with how they included this in the
game hiding it in plain sight
ever since the beginning of the division
one when playing through the game over
the years a number of people have
noticed the occasional event
where the player character would
suddenly fall through the map like the
ground would just disappear from beneath
them
the uproar from such situations usually
led to complaints on reddit and twitter
about how broken the game is but in
reality
it was 100 working as intended
kudos to those sneaky devs it must have
been hard holding onto this all those
years
they could have spilled the beans a long
time ago but in reality
it was all going to plan preparing for
the continuation of the story for a
pvp-based game
to be released seven or eight years in
the future
following the increasingly popular
real-world analysis of quantum mechanics
known as the mini world's interpretation
the idea behind falling through the
world in a way
like a glitch in the matrix is where
sudden holes in reality have opened up
gateways to the other worlds running
along the same timeline
now 99.9 of the time this sort of event
would result in the death of the
character
it's complicated to explain but summing
up the exact location and universe of
where the character is likely to be spat
out
is just one of trillions of
possibilities they could up appearing
miles above the ground
only to fall to their death or deep
underground
maybe in the middle of the ocean or
inside the stone walls of a large
building
in fact i think i've had that one happen
to me a number of times so sneaky those
developers
so the cleaners and outcasts that we see
in xd are some of the few that have
survived
it's unclear whether they're all sucked
through at the same time or if this is
the result of them coming together over
the years
who knows how many other factions have
been vacuumed into this world maybe
we'll be seeing them in future updates
to the game
so why are they fighting good question
this isn't immediately obvious when
watching the trailers
while the difference in each faction is
fairly straightforward
echelon versus ghosts there would be a
few carry-on hostilities between these
two groups
from the aurora conflict then there is
the cleaners and the outcasts
where one group was established as a
solution to the virus by burning it away
and the other just wanted to spread it
there is a pretty clear difference in
goals here
and don't even get me started on the
great tom clancy culinary conflict of
2024
neighborhood bake off savories were
burnt comments were made
feelings were hurt we won't go there
that's probably its own video
but in this tom clancy universe the
universe of xd
these factions have put their petty
differences aside due to something much
much larger at play
[Music]
think tom clancy's rainbow six siege how
the whole premise of the game is just a
training simulator between the operators
except instead of potential worldwide
terrorist attacks it's the rapidly
spreading need
to dance think zombies except
dancing these defiants are training in
these simulations
to prepare for their offensive push
against these zombies
who will stop at nothing to ensure
everyone is locked into a trance
and getting down with their bad bad
selves kind of like the party rock
anthem music video come to think of it
all i can say is this is a ubisoft
crossover like we've never seen before
the division ghost recon splinter cell
just dance
i can't wait to see what other factions
will be included in this list
the hunters assassins rayman the options
are endless
ubisoft you [ __ ] legends i applaud
you for not being held back
by the intricacies of the decades of
genre and world building content that
you have under your belt
and rather continue to follow the system
that you've been known for and excelled
in for 20 plus years
that you are instead willing to throw it
all in to follow the generic
industry trends of what many many other
publishers started doing
a long time before you
i hate that i have to say this but i've
been surprised by comments in the past
this video was absolutely 100 a pistak
after i started receiving questions
around the story of this new game i
thought
screw it everything has a story even if
you have to speculate far beyond reason
to get there
i am completely alongside the vocal
majority talking about how this misused
tom clancy name is in the title
i can only assume following the same
sort of path as hyperscape that they
were attempting to give this call of
duty clone a bit of a boost in initial
sales
through the use of the tom clancy name
and the factions that we all know and
love
consideration to the law and universes
has been completely disregarded
and while they state that this was only
inspiration that was taken from those
titles to build these factions
the fact that tom clancy is in the title
of the game makes this whole idea
completely misleading
i'm under no crazy allusion to the fact
that a number of younger gamers these
days
don't really give a [ __ ] about the story
or the tom clancy name
but it's the existing consumers of the
ubisoft brand who have been completely
[ __ ]
on i'm probably going to expand on this
in another video
but the recent announcements from
ubisoft over the last few years have
left me speechless
i mean what the actual [ __ ] are they
doing up there
surely a four almost five billion dollar
company has some sort of consumer
relations or customer experience team
if not i know a guy with experience in
this area although i'm sure the level of
honesty i've provided in this video
probably hasn't been particularly well
received
anyway this has been a bit of a
different video for me i'm sure a few of
you are confused
but some of this had to be said i
probably had way too much fun making
this video so i can't guarantee there
won't be more of these in the future
otherwise hopefully you enjoyed this and
i'll um catch in the next one
cheers [ __ ]
[Music]
okay